Dann fangen wir an.
Dann fangen wir an. Bitte schön.
Okay.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Akin.
Ich bin Asst. Ars aus der Station und für Sie zuständig.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmegespräch hören.
Falls Sie nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben,
sagen Sie mir jederzeit Bescheid.
Dann mache ich eine kurze Pause und beantworte Ihre Fragen.
Zunächst werde ich mit allgemeinen Fragen beginnen.
Anschließend werde ich auf Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden eingehen.
Ist das in Ordnung so für Sie?
Das ist super, ja. Vielen Dank.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie da?
Mein Name ist Sabine Krüger.
Sabine Krüger. Können Sie bitte Ihren Namen langsam beschreiben?
Mein Vorname ist S wie Siegfried, A wie Anton,
B wie Werther, I wie Ida, N wie Nordpol, E wie Emil.
Mein Name ist Krüger, K wie Konrad, R wie Richard,
U wie Ü, G wie Gustav, E wie Emil, R wie Richard.
Ja, Frau Krüger, richtig?
Richtig.
Okay, Frau Krüger, wie alt sind Sie und könnten Sie mir Ihr Geburtsdatum verraten?
Ich bin geboren am 22. September 1961. Ich bin 64 Jahre alt.
64?
Richtig.
Okay. Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,65 Meter groß und wiege ungefähr 75 Kilogramm.
75 Kilogramm. Okay. Frau Krüger, was für Sie ist um mir? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit drei Tagen starke Schmerzen im Unterbauch habe.
Und die Üblichkeit habe ich auf Fieber.
Und Fieber. Okay, ich verstehe, Frau Krüger. Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau lokalisieren?
Sie haben gesagt Unterbauch. Richtig?
Ich habe Unterbauchschmerzen. Die sind eher im linken Unterbauch.
Linken Unterbauch. Okay. Und haben Sie auch Fieber?
Ich habe gestern Abend noch mal gemessen. Das war ungefähr 38,6 Grad.
6 Grad. Okay. Welche Körperteile haben Sie gemessen? Auf die Songe oder auf die Achsel?
Ich habe an der Achsel gemessen.
Achsel gemessen.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen? Paracetamol oder Buprofen?
Genau, ich habe Paracetamol mehrmals eingenommen.
Mehrmals. Das hat geholfen?
Das Fieber ist zurückgegangen, aber die Schmerzen sind geblieben.
Okay. Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwann aus?
Strahlen so ein bisschen in die Leiste rein.
Leiste. Linken Leiste. Richtig?
Richtig. Genau.
Linken. Okay. Könnten Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Ich meine, ist er dumpf oder störend?
Es ist ein drückender, stöchender Schmerz.
Drückender?
Drückender, stöchender Schmerz.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10,
vorbei 1 der Allerke Schmerzen und 10 unverträgliche Schmerzen einsprich?
Wo würden Sie einordnen?
Ungefähr bei 6 bis 7.
6 oder 7.
Und so.
Neben der Schmerzen haben Sie andere Beschwerden.
Ich meine Durchfall oder Verstopfung oder Erbrechen.
Ich habe eher etwas Verstopfung, aber das ist auch wechselnd.
Seit wann bei Ihnen Verstopfung und Durchfall?
Das auch so seit 3 Tagen ungefähr. 3, 4 Tage.
3 Tage.
Haben Sie Stuhlveränderung, Farbe bemerkt?
Nein.
Schwarzstuhl oder?
Gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen?
Ich würde sagen mit Essen, Verbunden oder anderen.
Was würden Sie sagen?
Habe ich nicht gemerkt jetzt.
Okay. Und ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein. Ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Keine Übelkeit.
Und diese Schmerzen?
Erstmals oder hatten Sie solche Schmerzen früher?
Ich habe das schon mal gehabt vor ein, zwei Jahren.
Das ist aber von selbst wieder zu, hat sich selbst gebessert.
Waren Sie bei anderen Arzt wegen der Schmerzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Und Frau Krüger, haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Ich meine Antreibschlossigkeit oder Erschöpfunggefühl oder andere Beschwerden?
Nein. Ein bisschen Appetitlosigkeit aber sonst eigentlich nicht.
Okay. Okay, Frau Krüger.
Ich würde Ihnen jetzt alle gemeinden Befinden stellen.
Haben Sie Sterfrost oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Und haben Sie im Laufe der Zeit starke Ungewöhnliche abgenommen?
Ich habe keine gewissermaßen Verlust.
Keine. Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Okay. Verspüren Sie fanglagsame oder schnelle Herzschlag oder Herzrasen oder Herzkörper?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Krüger.
So, ich möchte jetzt in Ihrer medizinischen Vorgeschichte erhalten.
Gibt es Vorerkröckungen, von denen ich wissen sollte? Chronische Erkröckungen?
Ich habe eine Schilddrillenunterfunktion.
Ich nehme dagegen L-Tyroxin 75 Mikrogramm ein.
Einmal?
Einmal morgens.
Seit wann bestehenden Schilddrillenunterfunktionen bei Ihnen?
Ich habe die Schilddrillenunterfunktion schon seit 30 Jahren.
30 Jahre. Okay. Und andere?
Und Bluthochdruck habe ich.
Bluthochdruck habe ich.
Auch seit 20 Jahren ungefähr.
20 Jahre lang.
Ich nehme dafür Ramipril morgens einmal ein.
5 Milligramm.
5 Milligramm. Und das war's oder noch andere?
Das war's, ja.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert, Frau Krüger?
Ich wurde einmal an der Gebärmotor operiert.
Und da wurden Myome entfernt.
Wann würden Sie schon operiert?
Das war jetzt vor 5 Jahren.
Vor 5 Jahren.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Frau Krüger, sind bei Ihnen eine bestimmte Allergie bekannt?
Nein.
Haben Sie auch Unverträglichkeit gegen Lemanz, Mittell oder andere?
Nicht das, ich wüsste, nein.
Nein. Okay.
Ich möchte jetzt über Ihr Lebensstil sprechen, Frau Krüger.
Darf ich fragen, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Nein. Und haben Sie schon geraucht oder nicht?
Ich habe noch nie geraucht, nein.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Selten. Sehr, sehr selten.
Nur bei Geburtstagen oder bei Feiern.
Vielleicht 4-5 Mal im Jahr.
Okay.
So, Frau Krüger, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Okay. Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie schon es probiert?
Nein, noch nie.
Nein. Okay.
Okay. Ich verstehe, Frau Krüger.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Verkäuferin im Supermarkt.
Verkäuferin im Supermarkt.
Und wie ist die Familie stand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei erwachsene Kinder, ja.
Zwei erwachsene Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja.
Ja. Okay. Wohnen Sie mit RV zusammen?
Mit meinem Ehemann.
Ja, Ehemann.
Ja.
Okay. Und Ihrer Frau Krüger, gibt es in Ihren Eltern eine chronische Erkrückung?
Meine Eltern sind beide verstorben.
Meine Mutter hatte auch Bluthochdruck.
Und mein Vater ist leider an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Ich möchte Sie fragen, wie alt sind oder wie alt ist er als Staat?
Er war 78 Jahre alt.
78 Jahre alt.
Und was ist mit der Mutter? War sie gestorben?
Meine Mutter ist leider an Demenz verstorben.
Demenz.
Ich habe schnell fortstreitende Demenz bekommen und daran ist sie gestorben.
Okay. Ich verstehe.
Ja, Frau Krüger, ich bin mit beiden Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas für uns erfüllen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ich habe aktuell keine Fragen. Nein, ich würde nur gerne wissen, was für Erkrankungen ich habe.
Okay. Ja, ich verstehe, Frau Krüger.
Wir haben jetzt nur das Aufnahmegespräch beendet.
Ich werde die körperliche Untersuchung durchführen und Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und können wir zusammen herausfinden, was dahintersteckt oder was ist die Ursache der Beschwerden?
Jetzt habe ich leider keine genaue Diagnose.
Aber ich habe jetzt nur Verdacht.
Ja.
Soll ich warten oder was glauben Sie, was ich habe?
Ja, wir werden weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Und wir müssen einige Blutuntersuchungen erzielen.
Dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose und weitere Schritte sprechen.
Alles klar.
Ja.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Keine Fragen.
Wichtige oder nicht wichtige?
Wichtig.
Ja oder nicht?
In Deutschland werden normalerweise auf 50 Jahre generell Vorsorge darmspiegelungen empfohlen.
Man kann fragen, wann war Ihre letzte Darmspiegelung? War alles in Ordnung? Ist das festgestellt worden oder nicht?
Das kann man fragen.
Letzte Darmspiegelung war vor 10 Jahren. Da war alles in Ordnung.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön.
Die Reiseanemese, können Sie sagen, dass waren Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland?
Ich war nicht im Ausland, nein.
Sind Sie total geimpft?
Ich denke ja.
Ok, danke.
Unterhalten Sie Sport oder gehen Sie sich?
Leider nicht. Wollen wir das Arzt-Ausgespräch beginnen?
Ja.
Ok, danke.
Ok, guten Tag Herr Oberst. Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und ich möchte Sie Ihnen vorstellen, wenn Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich haben.
Ja gerne, bitte schön.
Ok, der Patient heißt Sabina Krüger. Er ist 64 Jahre alt. Sie ist 1,65 cm groß und 75 kg schwer.
Frau Krüger stellte sich bei uns wegen seit drei Tagen plötzlich aufgetretener, bestehender Abdominalschmerzen im linken Bereich.
Unterbau.
Unterbauch, ja, Unterbauch oder Unterabdome.
Ja, Unterbauch.
Frau, die Schmerzen würden im linken Leistenbereich ausgetragen.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie 38,6 C auf Achseln fielen.
Die Patienten erwähnten, dass diese Schmerzen drückende und stände seien.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 oder 7 von 10.
Die Patienten berichteten, dass sie seit drei Tagen paroxysmale Verstopfung, Obst, und Gero leiden.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufhörlich bis auf Inapetens.
Die Patienten erwähnten, dass sie vor 10 Jahren eine Koloskopie durchgeworfen wurde.
Es gab keine Auffälligkeit.
Die Patienten leiden an der folgenden chronischen Erkrankung.
Sie leiden an Hypothrodyse seit 30 Jahren.
Sie leiden an Arterielle Hypertonie seit 20 Jahren.
Sie leiden an Ramiplil 5,1.
Sie leiden an Myomyotomy seit 5 Jahren.
Sie leiden an Alkohol, Drogen, und Noxon.
Sie ist Verkauferin in einem Supermarkt verheiratet und sie hat zwei Erwachsene.
Sie wohnt mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Ihr Vater und ihre Mutter waren beide gestorben.
Seine Mutter leidet an Bluthochdruck und Demenz.
Ihr Vater war an Herzinfarkt gestorben.
Aufgrund der anämenistischen Angaben gehe ich von Verdacht auf die Vertikulitis aus.
Die Diagnostik kommt aus Differenzielle Diagnostik.
Kolonkarsenon, Inguinal Herni und OVR-Karsenon in Befragt.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Ich empfehle eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich achte darauf, ob es eine Verspannung gibt.
Bei der Blutuntersuchung rüffe ich CRP, BCG, kleine Blutbilder und Kahlprotekt.
Bei der Abdominalzonographie achte ich darauf, ob es eine Flüssigkeitssammlung gibt.
Wenn CRP und Leukocytin erhöht sind, würden Sie auch noch etwas anderes machen?
Wenn die entzündlichen Parameter wie CRP und Leukocytin erhöht sind, würde ich eine Diktat oder Kolon auf Kolon beitragen.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich meine, außer einen Ultraschall würden Sie eine andere Diagnostik machen.
Ja, eine andere Diagnostik würde ich eine komputerische Tomographie und Koloskopie durchführen.
Man würde erst abwarten, bis die Entzündungswerte weniger geworden sind.
Man kann im CT, also in einer komputerischen Tomographie auch sehen, ob es eine Divertikulierung ist oder nicht.
Mit Hilfe der komputerischen Tomographie können wir die Divertikulierung feststellen.
Was machen Sie dann therapeutisch?
Bei Bestätigung von Verdacht auf Divertikulierung würde ich eine Antibiotikatherapie einleiten.
Und Flüssigkeit, Sufol und Schmerz-adaptierte Therapie.
Was würden Sie als Antibiotiker geben?
Zuerst würde ich eine Sechthreaktion oder eine zweite Genesis-Sechthreaktion, Sephalosporin einleiten.
Würden Sie kein Amoklaf geben und mit Reninazole vielleicht zusammen?
Ja, und mit zusammen Metronidazole oder Ornadiazole verschleben oder verabreichen.
Aber wenn die Entzündung weniger geworden ist, dann sollten Sie auf jeden Fall eine Koloskopie machen, richtig?
Ja, richtig.
Sehr gut. Alles richtig gemacht.
Danke.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Vergänzungen, Korrigierungen, Korrekturen?
In einem mystischen Angabe, Sie haben gesagt, eine Myomektomie oder Hysteriktomie?
Ich habe Myome entfernt gesagt.
Okay, danke.
Gibt es sonst Fragen? Sie können jede Frage stellen, wenn Sie wollen.
Wann sollen wir die Koloskopie durchführen? Gibt es einen bestimmten Zeitraum?
Wenn die Entzündungswerte weniger geworden sind, wenn Sie zum Beispiel einen CRP haben von 100,
dann sollten Sie keine Koloskopie machen, weil dann die Gefahr einer Darmpräferation erhöht ist.
Aber wenn Sie von 100 auf 20 runtergegangen sind, dann können Sie überlegen, ob Sie eine Koloskopie machen.
Ich verstehe, dass es keinen bestimmten Zeitraum gibt.
Nein, das ist bei jedem anders.
Also, man sollte warten, bis die Entzündungswerte runtergegangen sind, und dann sollte man eine Koloskopie machen.
Entweder stationär oder poststationär.
Wir haben schon mit der Computertomographie gesehen, dass es eine Divertigütis ist.
Kann man in der Ultraschale etwas sehen bei Divertigütis?
Das kann man auch sehen, aber nicht immer.
Es ist nicht immer gut, aber man kann definitiv in der Ultraschale eine Divertigütis sehen.
Die Gefahr besteht immer unter einer gedeckt präferierten Divertigütis.
Das sieht man im CT meistens besser.
Wenn die erste Verwaltung der Darmpräferung normal ist,
dann kann man in der Ultraschale eine Divertigütis sehen.
Wie lange dauert das?
In 10 Jahren wieder.
In 10 Jahren.
Weitere Fragen?
Okay.
Gut, dann vielen, vielen Dank.